[Music]
just wanted to hear banging songs yeah
man
and i know i put out at least half the
banging rap joins us out there so you
know if i stop it's over with
dmx has died the rapper's death follows
his hospitalization after suffering a
heart attack
triggered by a drug overdose dmx turned
50
in december i just want to continue to
do what i do you know work hard with the
music don't compromise
the music e.t learned that medical staff
at his home
tried to revive him twice and he was
later revived
again at a hospital in white plains new
york
a source close to the rapper and actor
told et that dmx recently relapsed with
his drug addiction
and previously suffered from kovid 19.
the source added that before he died
dmx's family was by his bedside holding
his hand
and praying amid his initial
hospitalization
a rep for the family told et quote he is
in a medical state from which i don't
think he will recover
the rough riders to the rescue
foundation organized a vigil outside of
dmx's hospital
god
[Music]
dmx sold over 74 million records across
his decades spanning career in the music
industry
[Music]
the rapper was nominated for three
grammy awards and he won
favorite rap hip-hop artist at the amas
in 2000.
i was the first artist to do two out two
platinum albums in one year you know i
should have got it then
it's the feeling you know you feel what
i say if you're listening you know if
not you just feel the beat you know
but it's there it's strong you know it's
deep every song
and type album you can put it on and you
know just let it play you know you don't
have to skip oh put it on seven and back
to 12 and you know you
have to do all that let it play i'm dmx
three of his albums were certified
platinum including his third studio
album
and then there was x which included his
most successful song
party up
[Music]
up
[Music]
and it wasn't long before dmx's success
extended to hollywood
he started movies like romeo must die
and exit wounds
all right don't know what to do dmx even
pulled double duty for the film cradled
to the grave
where on the set he was both acting and
recording music for the soundtrack
i mean we had a uh we had a studio bus
on the set you know and sometimes like
i'd wrap it maybe
two o'clock and i beat it like seven in
the morning on the studio bus
amid dmx's struggles with drug addiction
as well as legal troubles over the years
he remained a deeply religious person do
you have a drug problem now
i will always have a drug problem just
because you stopped getting high
doesn't mean that you don't have the
problem because it's a constant fight
every day every trigger that was a true
you know it was a trigger when you got
it's still a trigger whether you act on
it or not it's a lonely feeling it's a
lonely feeling